c'était le 5 mai dernier la première
d'une série de manifestations musclées
sur le littoral de sainte luce ici se
succèdent 16 parcelles différentes 14
propriétaires 35 copropriétaires et tous
engage des poursuites pour voies de fait
contre leurs installations mais aussi le
préjudice moral subi suite vous
intrusions répétées sur leur propriété
pour la première fois l'une de leurs
avocats s'exprime en leur nom ils ont
subi une agression de voir des gens
débouler chez eux le 5 mai et
l'agression elle est continue puisque
les gens continuent à venir en pensant
qu'ils sont chez eux alors que si n'est
pas le cas et ce n'est pas le cas
pourquoi parce que l'état n'a pas encore
dit où se situe le semaine et orale donc
pour le moment ils sont penchés ya des
personnes âgées qui vivent là on est
même déjà rentrer chez elle
enfin la l'application de la législation
ne justifie en rien l'agression
permanente et les dégâts matériels
dégradation des clôtures de murs ou
encore de carbet évaluation des dégâts
est en cours mais leur indemnisation ne
relève pas du tout des assurances mais
bien du tribunal correctionnel
entre temps les choses avancent sur le
terrain ce mois ci les géomètres de
l'adea allons portage de délimiter
précisément le littoral avant de définir
mètre par mètre le tracé du futur
sentier état communes les propriétaires
doivent travailler ensemble et lancer
les enquêtes publiques
donc on ne dira pas si le chemin passe
devant chez eux à côté de chez eux ou
peu importe pour le moment on ne sait
pas on se situe sans sentier littoral
donc il demande à ce qu'ils aient une
certaine sérénité qui reviennent à un
soir milla désert que les choses se
fassent dans le temps de la procédure et
que dans l'intervalle laisser les gens
vivre normalement chez eux car le thon
peut être encore long avant la mise en
place légal de la servitude littoral
voulue par le décret d'août 2010 en ce
sens le cas de sainte luce est un peu un
laboratoire avant les procédures qui
devront sans doute s'engager dans
d'autres communes de l'île